Just recently, now in August, Skilled AI
published oneshot action learning for
robots. So, a robot learns a procedure
just from one video. What is really
amazing? But in the assembly context,
there's the question, what procedures
should a robot actually learn? Sure, you
can teach a robot every single step with
a video, but is that the right way for
manufacturing processes with a high
level of variability?
We think graph machine learning can play
a role here, predicting which components
of an assembly actually belong together
and in which sequence they need to be
mounted.
Even when wheels can one day do this
independently,
graphs can still support creating better
structured representations,
supporting change management, or helping
with quality checks.
So, graphs don't replace robot
foundation models, they support them. I
am Kristoff Yan. I work as an engineer
at Mercedes-Benz and I do research in
machine learning at the University of
Constance.